let's try our caller from the four zero
one area code who's calling today from
four zero one does that mean yes it is
Hey Bruce David my question was about
the WH o with Bruce Aylward have you
heard anything about that is this the
guy who was asked about how Taiwan did
and he just like first he said he
couldn't hear the question
then he disconnected on skype and when
they reconnected he was like oh you
already asked me about that ask me about
something else yeah I mean listen it
certainly does not inspire confidence
that when we hear from the WH oh how
great China's doing that it's true right
I mean you know one of the things we
suspected early on was that China had
way more cases than they were telling
the truth about eventually China claimed
to have mitigated the spread and one of
the things that sort of allayed our
fears that china was lying was that
w-h-o officials were in the country and
they were saying no no no china really
is doing that well when then you get a
whu-oh official who's asked hey but how
about how Taiwan did and the guy first
pretends not to hear the question then
hangs up and then refuses to answer it
certainly suggests political bias of the
type that makes me question whether
we're getting reliable numbers out of
China so so for me it made me think the
problem maybe has not actually been
solved in China yeah that's right like I
have study Mandarin Chinese I've been
around people while my whole campus
actually has a whole like Chinese part
of the campus and they're all freaking
out about that because a lot of them are
from Taiwan or Hong Kong and things like
that they're like how do we trust how
can we go back home how can we do this
kind of thing certainly helping us well
it doesn't seem that Taiwan and Hong
Kong are the ones potentially being
dishonest though right I mean it's in
that sense it's not a concern no yeah
but they're like if the World Health
Organization is not looking out for us
and how do we know what's actually true
with Apple fair enough yeah no that's
definitely concerned when I saw that
video it was extraordinarily
serving and makes me question question
the Chinese data and listen I mean when
we look at data we should probably just
not even look at China like let's just
exclude China when we look at growth
rates when we look at mitigation you
know look at South Korea as a successful
example look at Taiwan look at some
other places I don't know how much of an
advantage there is to even including
China in the data at this point like we
know what needs to be done we know what
can be done China's numbers we may never
really know is where I am at this point
all right yeah well thank you so much
for your time all right thank you for
the call let's take a quick break we
will go right back to the phones after
the break so if you are holding don't
hang up because we are getting right
back to phone calls momentarily